if that's the word we're going to use
has bearings on things okay what do you
mean what do you mean when you say that
okay cool for the example that you just
gave like if a man said i don't wanna
date a girl with kids i don't wanna
cool going back to what we were just
discussing men control the market is my
belief so
naturally their preferences their
beliefs where they place value is going
to have bearings on the market i'm in
the market
well when we say it we don't really have
that much control no but we do we do we
do we do guys guys we do we do because
we are in control of sex and in 2022 sex
tends to come before relationships
so
knowing that
in a way we're in control of
relationships women control who they
sleep with so in a way women are in
control of the market i mean you could
argue right that a small i could see the
argument that a small percentage of men
control the market but women are way
more influential than men you really
believe that yeah i mean we